A major thing I’ve discussed recently is
deck consistency, and I’ve been surprised
by how much feedback I’ve gotten, in multiple
dimensions—I’ve had people telling me
that I’m besmirching the spirit of a singleton
format, but I’ve also had a lot of people
who were interested and genuinely curious
about how to make a deck consistent.
So, I figure for this video I can spend 10
minutes yelling at that first group about
how wrong they are.
Alright, listen here ya bozos—no, those
people are entitled to their deckbuilding
preferences, and I wish them well.
I actually want to give a more detailed look
at deck consistency as a subject, with an
emphasis on the how—what’s the best way
to turn a floppy pile of jank into a well-oiled
machine?
To get there, I want to start by clarifying
my terms.
I throw around the phrase “consistent deck”
a lot, and one interpretation of a consistent
deck is one that does the same thing every
game.
I think this is a very incomplete definition
for what I’m talking about, and the definition
I’m going to use instead is that a consistent
deck is one that consistently does something,
and whose things it does don’t vary all
that much in power level.
This often means decks with multiple avenues
of play whose construction is good enough
that the different options all feel valuable.
The three decks I mentioned in my last video,
my $25 Rakdos deck, my Meria deck, and my
Glissa deck, all basically do variations on
a theme.
With Glissa, the deck might take different
opening plays depending on the game, but at
the end of the day its general game plan will
be ramp, play big stuff, and gain board dominance.
Similarly, with my Meria deck, the deck is
always looking to play a bunch of equipments
and swing big in the midgame, but that can
take a lot of different shapes.
If you want to learn more about the Meria
deck, I recently posted a ten minute deck
tech over on my patreon that covers the process
of how I built it, a breakdown of the list,
and some takeaways I had from the deckbuilding
process.
I’ve mentioned a handful of reasons I like
consistent decks in the past, and I’ll give
a brief rehash here.
From a table politics standpoint, people will
remember the most powerful moments of the
deck—your spooky pop-off win you can only
pull off 10% of the time will be remembered
alongside a more consistent deck’s quite
solid gameplan it pulls off 75% of the time,
and this will make your deck seem disproportionately
scary.
Even if table memory isn’t a concern, from
a fun standpoint I like to have my deck be
doing something every game.
This is doubly true when I’m playing with
new people, where my deck failing to get off
the ground will look an awful lot like I just
built a bad deck, rather than being seen as
the unfortunate sequence of draws it truly
was.
To be clear, this is absolutely an ego thing,
but fortunately for me, for the moment we
all have human brains that do silly human
brain things, so I know a decent portion of
you share in my vanity at the table.
Now that I’ve got the what and why out of
the way, let’s talk how.
For starters, I think one of the easier forms
of consistency to nail is what I like to call
“rollout consistency”.
This type of consistency basically asks the
question, “do I do what I want to do on
the first several turns of the game?”
That “what” can vary deck-to-deck, and
obviously you won’t play a turn 1 Sol Ring
every game, but you can check to make sure
that your deck is generally doing at least
*something* that feels good.
The best way of doing this is solo playtesting
a deck a whole bunch, and I generally playtest
my decks quite a lot before spending any money
on them.
However, this can be time consuming, and one
way of reducing this time is having a baseline
of probabilistic sense for the cards in your
deck so you’re at least in the general ballpark
with things.
Anybody who plays a lot of card games will
have this intuitively hammered in to an extent,
but just for fun here I’m gonna show you
exactly what I mean.
Let’s say I want to look at how often I
get a particular type of card by a particular
turn, using the example of a Goreclaw deck
I’ve been building.
The deck always wants to play the commander
by turn 3, and this means that it needs to
get a piece of ramp by turn 2, every game.
Disregarding mulligans, lands, and other factors,
the probability of this happening is modeled
by this function, where X is the number of
ramp spells in my deck, and it can be used
to graph out how likely it is to achieve this
goal based on that number.
As we can see on the graph, if I have 10 ramp
spells in the deck there’s a 63% chance
of having one on turn 2, if there’s 15 in
deck I have a 79% chance, if there’s 20
I have an 88% chance, and so on.
Alright, now let’s instead say I really
want to see ramp in the opening hand, and
will happily mulligan to get there.
If I decide to run 15 ramp spells, then for
a given seven card hand, there’s a 69.6%
chance of having at least one ramp spell,
and this graph lays out that probability based
on the number of hands drawn.
For one hand drawn it’s 69.6%, for two hands
drawn it’s 90.8%, for three hands drawn
it’s 97.2% of the time, and so forth.
A simple benchmark you can reference is that
you need 10 of a card in a deck to have it
show up in a given hand more than half the
time.
You could also do this sort of modeling for
a combo deck—for this hypothetical persist
combo deck running no tutors and no partial
pieces, in order to have a better-than-half
chance of drawing one of each piece to have
the combo, you need to draw roughly half the
deck, and there’s about a one in 400 chance
of drawing it in the opening hand.
Another possible calculation would be modeling
land drops given a certain land count.
By showing you this kind of modeling, I’m
certainly not trying to say that you should
go out and get a degree in math before building
a deck—I almost never run this sort of calculation
while deckbuilding.
What I am trying to say, though, is that it’s
good to have a rough idea of the actual numbers
of the situation.
I think a lot of people tend to underestimate
how many cards 100 actually is, and that tends
to result in people putting in less cards
with a particular effect than would be ideal.
This also then has other effects on the card
quality—you might build out the core of
the deck and then go “wow, I’ve got so
many slots left!
I could put all sorts of stuff in here.”
I’ve been there, and let me tell you, those
decks end up turning out way worse than decks
where I’m sweating and dying trying to find
space for everything.
When slots are plentiful, filler that weakens
the deck as a whole will work its way in,
cards where you go “oh this seems decent
in a couple niche situations” or “oh yeah
this card has slight synergies with some other
elements of the deck.”
These cards are probably there in place of
other, better-suited cards.
A good first step toward reducing this sort
of filler is to categorize your deck, and
think about the categories.
Different decks will use different systems,
but four supporting categories I usually have
are Ramp, Draw, Removal, and Protection, with
those last two categories sometimes combined
for decks whose interaction mainly consists
of counterspells.
Separating these out and making sure you have
enough of each is a good first step of making
sure that you’re spending slots on things
that will actually make your deck better,
rather than throwing in some random pet enchantments.
Within the categories, there might be the
question of whether a card truly belongs there.
For example, is Gilded Lotus ramp?
If you’re accelerating to ten or more mana
to play a lot of big threats, yes it is.
If you’re running ramp so that you can hit
a 6 mana commander consistently, no it’s
not ramp.
For draw, you should consider the difference
between conditional draw, general purpose
draw, and filtering, since if your deck relies
too heavily on conditional draw, you’ll
have games where you get behind and then stay
behind.
Once you’ve figured out your categories
and considered what sorts of cards *should*
make up a given category, the next question
might be how much of each to run, and this
will vary from deck to deck.
Things like draw and ramp can be tested via
playtesting, but reactive elements will be
trickier to figure out.
For removal I’d recommend starting between
8 and 14, and adjust from there keeping in
mind that slower decks and lower-velocity
decks will usually want more removal than
faster decks and higher-velocity decks will.
Protection is the most variable of all—I
run 0 in a couple scrappy decks that don’t
give a shit about anything, and 12 in the
Meria deck whose supporting categories are
currently on screen, where my commander staying
alive an extra turn might mean a dead opponent
and a bunch of value.
How much protection is correct for your deck
will depend on how much it cares about its
commander and other key cards surviving—
and if you care a lot about that, I’d like
to remind you that if you’re only running
the two boots, your odds of drawing protection
in your first five draws of the game of the
game are [tapping] a hair under 23%.
That’s not great!
A helpful side effect of categorizing is that
it will naturally leave some cards in undeniably
naked view.
If a card doesn’t fit into one of your key
categories, you should be asking yourself
what its purpose is, and the answer should
be simple and straightforward.
If the answer involves scratching your head
and vaguely gesturing at a couple other cards,
that’s a card that deserves a more robust
evaluation.
In my mind, the optimal state of a decklist
is one whose components exist in comfortable
tension in your mind—where there are constantly
questions in the back of your mind like “hmmm,
should I swap out a ramp spell and a finisher
slot for two more draw spells?”
The answer to that can be no, but asking that
kind of question in the first place will improve
your decks and make you better at deckbuilding.
A final type of consistency I want to talk
about is one that’s complex enough that
I might make a full video about it at some
point, and that is situational consistency.
By this phrase I made up on the spot I mean
a deck that plays relatively smoothly in a
bunch of different situations—you could
also call this being reactive and/or being
resilient depending on context.
This will generally mean devoting deck space
to specific types of suppressive or protective
cards, and the best way to allow a deck to
have easy access to situational cards without
destroying the deck’s general consistency
is tutors.
This could mean running a bunch of the black
classics, but those tend to be expensive,
either money-wise or mana-wise, so for a deck
looking to run a bunch of tutors, a natural
place to end up is often what’s called a
“toolbox” deck.
This refers to a deck with a number of conditional
tutors that can each grab cards useful in
several different situations.
A couple quintessential toolbox cards are
Birthing Pod and Yisan, the Wanderer Bard,
which work well in decks with a lot of card
diversity at each mana cost.
There are some really powerful toolbox decks
out there, as higher powers are where being
able to consistently find tech pieces and
answers really shines.
For a couple examples of toolbox decks at
a lower power, I can talk about my Sharuum
Slide deck, and my friend Mr Hans’ Vadrok
deck.
In Sharuum Slide, the primary objective of
the toolbox is grabbing Astral Slide, but
there are a ton of other options embedded
into this enchantment, artifact, and wizard-based
tutoring framework—board wipes, recursion
spells, draw spells, life gain, and so forth.
This means that the deck can flow nicely once
it gets into the midgame, even though the
“interesting” mana base can often lead
to slow early games.
In the Vadrok deck, equipments are the primary
card type that the tutor base is oriented
around, with the equipment base containing
value, protection, defense, graveyard hate,
and Sunforger.
With Sunforger, the deck can hit a ton of
different cards, including a convoluted infinite
combo, which results in a mutate deck that’s
a little strange, but very fun and flexible.
As an end note to this section, I should probably
mention: I know that a lot of people dislike
tutors, and I think a lot of that dislike
comes from a particular type of usage.
Somebody tutors up a power card or a couple
combo pieces, and then explodes the table.
This might feel bland to play against, but
I want to pose a question—is it more interesting
when a deck draws into that explosive win
out of pure luck?
It’ll happen less often without tutors,
sure, but having the question of whether you’ll
lose to a two card infinite combo be up to
a roll of the dice rather than it being tutored
for doesn’t really seem better in any meaningful
sense.
If anything, it makes it more difficult to
run counterplay for that sort of deck—a
stax piece you throw in will sit un-utilized
the 85% of the time that they’re doing something
else.
My advice is this—if you don’t like a
particular type of wincon or a particular
power level, that’s fine, and there’s
probably a different table out there that
you’ll like better.
Alright, that’s this video coming to an
end.
I have two things to mention here—one, I
made a website, and put a couple probability
calculators up on it because I was bored and
wanted an excuse to practice my JavaScript.
So you can visit there if you want to know
the probability of drawing a card type by
a given turn, or the average turn you’ll
miss a land drop with a given land count.
Oooh, turn seven?
That’s pretty cool.
Secondly, I feel I should reiterate—as with
my last video, this is a style of deck building
that you can engage in, but not every deck
will be well-served by being transparent or
maximizing consistency.
Just leaving that out there.
Anyway, here’s a preview of the Meria deck
tech I recently posted
to my patreon: